Speaker 1: Former Donald Trump propagandist
Stephen Bannon is desperate, desperate for
Trump to stop with the NFT digital trading
cards. And there are actually slightly more
and more voices that are saying some of this
stuff is not going going particularly well.
Here is some kind of roundtable. I think
this was at america fest and Steve Bannon
is just not happy with the Trump nft grift. And I
understand that it is really it's really cringing.
Speaker 4: I have on my pillow. It's the
best. Oh, right, right. That's right. Oh,
my gosh. I have the travel pillow. I have the
slippers. I have it all. What about me? Don't
give her a promo code. Oh, come on. I'm broke.
There's other promo codes out there that am. I'm
just saying. Just saying, Mr. Lindell and
I don't need a promo code. I tell everyone
about it. Thank you. God bless you. Thank
you. If we give the president promo code,
can he stop with the notes? I'm just kidding. I'm
just kidding. Well, the NFT is that sold out in 12
hours. He's just jealous over here. Yeah. Yeah,
I know. That's a free and fair market. Just.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, Bannon knows the
entire Trump NAFTA thing is a complete and total
grift and scam. And you can just tell he can't
get away from the humiliation of that. We played
a clip yesterday of him saying whoever came up
with this idea should be fired. And it is very
interesting in the sense that some of the most
reliable, historically reliable and stalwart Trump
supporters, the confidants, the loyalists, they
are now mocking Trump pretty regularly. And part
of this maybe is the polling that they're seeing
may be to some degree, the writing is on the wall.
Here's another example, by the way. Here's a clip
of Matt Gaetz. I believe it's the exact same event
saying that on the issue of who should
be speaker, Donald Trump is wrong and
Gates is not the type of guy who would typically
distance himself or draw distinctions with Trump.
Speaker 4: A couple of unpleasant facts. Let's get
them on the table. Number one, President Trump has
said the other day The New York Times broke that
he was whipping votes for Kevin McCarthy. And then
President Trump gave the great Matt Boyle at
Breitbart an exclusive interview and he said,
Hey, I think Kevin's earned it. President Trump
President Trump is both from whipped votes here,
and he's come out and told Breitbart and
Matt Boyle that he's actually supporting
Kevin McCarthy. I adore him. That's right.
What about this is the Trump policy right
here? I can't wait to vote for Donald Trump in
the 2024 election. But if Donald Trump believes
that Kevin McCarthy should be speaker of the
House, then Donald Trump is wrong. Wow. Donald
Trump has not always nailed it on the front. I
remember having a fight against Jeff Sessions and
Mattis and Rex Tillerson. So President Trump
is the leader of our movement. He sets the
vision. But Donald Trump has not moved a single
vote when it comes to the people considering
how to cast their lot in the speaker's race.
Speaker 1: Wow. So not only think about that,
not only is Gates saying he disagrees with Trump
about who should be speaker of the House when
Republicans take over in January, he's saying
Trump isn't even influencing even a single person
in the House of Representatives to reconsider
or change how they are going to vote. That's
a pretty serious attack from a guy who has been a
Trump brown noser for years at this point in time,
and of course, will eventually know the answer.
But the hypothetical is the supposition. The
question is this a sign that the tide is turning?
The polling is sort of suggesting that and hearing
from people like Bannon and Gates suggests that
that also may be the way it is. We'll know more,
I believe, by something like April 1st. I
think it will be pretty clear. Another really
interesting thing that's going on is an intra
MAGA civil war. Let's talk about that next.